tinx the queen of the internet and now
you've affectionately earned the title
of
the internet's big sister i mean how
does that feel it's incredible it's
honestly such an honor
i always wanted a big sister myself so
the fact that people are calling me
their big sister
is so i'm just i'm honored and it feels
great and i love it i do feel like
they're all my little sisters out there
my mom always jokes she's like i feel
like you're
the president of this really big
imaginary sorority and i'm like yeah
kind of sure right kappa alpha internet
reigning supreme and i think the reason
why
you have really exploded and really
resonated with so many people is because
you are so authentically you guys look
at what kim kardashian sent me men
are so predictable the day after i tell
tic toc that i have a boyfriend
diplo sends me his crocs collab the
mindset should be
do i like this guy is he good enough for
me does he have a headboard
what are the tenants of tink's culture
tank's culture wow
well it it really runs the gamut ting's
culture it's
shrimp cocktail but it's also knowing
your self-worth it's
botox it's boys it's where to get the
best
martini in town it's a little bit of
everything it's very niche that's what i
love about you you're so specific with
the
body tell your followers yes everything
that i do is very specific because i
think
you know if you tell someone oh go to
this restaurant that's great
but if you tell them you've got to go on
a wednesday because that's when this
exact pastry chef is in
is working and you've got to order this
exact breakfast
and make sure you you stop to get a
coffee here after like that's
worth its weight in gold life is short
and we have limited time and we have
limited resources so if you're gonna
spend time or money on something it
better be good
love all the kardashians i really
respect and admire them
love food love travel love beauty um
and i really just love taking care of
myself and in a really fun way
i kind of want to just back up a little
bit you joined
tick-tock uh which is of course where we
can see all of these things explored on
your page
can you kind of tell me the story of
when you joined tick tock and why you
joined tick tock
totally so i i always tell my followers
if you
if you haven't found your thing yet and
you're in your young 20s don't worry i'm
i'm 30 now i found my passion when i was
29
like so many people i downloaded tiktok
in quarantine
and before that i was a writer and i
i never thought of myself as an
on-camera person but i was like you know
what
i'm loving tic toc i might as well try
to make some things and make a few
videos and as soon as i made my first
video i knew that that is what i was
supposed to do for the rest of my life
met mike
when i was walking down the street and
he went yo that ass is fat
and i um i was like this ass and he was
like that is
i joined in may of last year and i hit a
million almost to the week
um a year later so it was really really
emotional and crazy just to think
wow what a crazy year can you think of
the
one video that really changed the game
for you where you noticed
i think i'm on to something here and i
decided to
go to um drive to the valley to try the
kardashian salad
and i thought like that health nut is my
favorite oh my gosh i'm obsessed with it
the kardashians are obsessed with health
nut salad
and i'm obsessed with the kardashians
earlier this year in lockdown i was
getting ready for my daily cry and i was
like you know what i'm going to drive to
the valley get me one of those salads
and that's when i thought wow this is
really fun i love being like the
spokesperson for all these people who
have the same questions and curiosities
about
la and celebrities that i have and and i
can i can be a middleman
you're like i volunteer as tribute i
don't go to hell
exactly your content creation process
is it something that you get random
bursts of inspiration
do you script things i mean what goes
into making
one of the videos that goes up on your
page it totally depends i have a couple
different
format pillars you know i have my rich
moms and they take a lot of
of research i mean i have to get that
right mom starter pack malibu edition
so you were an actress on a terrible tv
show for about five minutes you're
moving to tribeca first things first
you're gonna need an apartment in 443
greenwich so your kids feel safe away
from the paparazzi
rich mom starter pack miami edition 30
million dollar condo at the four seasons
something that screams
i'm single and 23 even though you're 40
and have four kids
if it's just a hot take i'll literally
pull over on the side of the road and do
it with my i have a mini mic in my car
and i'll you know
i'll just fire those off sometimes i
just want to be inside on my couch
without feeling like i should be going
down a slip and slide blackout in
someone famous backyard i'm basically
making content 24 hours a day so it's
really erratic it's really all over the
place but
i it's i'm at my most happy when i'm
when i'm making content
is there any topic that's off limits
gosh not really i never want to create
an unrealistic standard for
happiness or for life so i don't want my
followers think oh wow her life is
perfect like i have to show myself
crying in the car or breaking down or
like having a tough day
when i'm dealing with anxiety because
that's life
100 and that reminds me of something
that you say often that i really
appreciate
you're like this face it's not just
because i'm i'm well rested and i drink
water
full transparency i eat a lot of salads
like i'm not here to
sugar coat it you know what i mean
totally i'm really honest about it and
and you know i
like i have botox i tell my followers i
love it
and that's why i look like this so i i
again try to be like you know what guys
like
i eat salad in the week and on the
weekend i have like 40 margaritas in
froyo and it's called 80 20 and we and
we balance and and that's
and that's what it is so always trying
to keep it real well i think that
transparency and that authenticity has
not only resonated with like your your
core
tinks followers but you've garnered the
attention of celebrities you've got the
the kardashians sending you pr boxes
gwyneth paltrow who i know is like a
huge huge hero of yours
what does it mean to have all of this
celebrity adoration
it's i mean it's totally incredible you
asked about my process and i was lying
in bed and i was
on instagram and i was seeing all the
influencers get the chocolate box that
kim sends out for the perfume and
i was like god i wonder what it tastes
like i cannot be the only fat ass who
thinks about all the chocolate that goes
to waste
the next morning i woke up the tick tock
had gone viral and i had a dm
from uh kim's team being like we want to
send you the box and it was just
such a cool moment because that's again
what i try to do is like not just
do the unboxing but like do the unboxing
that every girl out there would do and
most people would take a bite of their
freaking chocolate and it was delicious
she works with this like fancy
chocolatier and it was
the best part that i've ever had yeah i
still have some in my freezer i'm saving
it
wow okay so you're getting pr packages
have you been able to
personally connect with the kardashians
i know you just went to
kendall's uh 818 tequila lunch i mean
did you have a chance to chat there
i chatted briefly with her she is even
more stunning in person
was such a nice such a nice girl and it
was a really
it was crazy to be at that party
honestly i think i started blabbing
about my breakup and she was like i'm
really sorry she was so sweet to me and
yeah gwyneth paltrow was huge
inspiration to me she dm'd me and said
she'd seen my rich mom videos and i was
just like
oh my god i want to get into some of
these signature
tinks mantras and theories
let's start with mantras what are some
of your mantras that you live by that
you think people could
from could benefit from knowing a little
bit more about my number one that i live
by
is comparison is the thief of joy and it
really changed my life
don't compare yourself to your friends
don't compare yourself to people on the
internet
don't even compare yourself to your own
future self the key to happiness is
staying present and staying grateful and
knowing that everybody
is on their own timeline men always come
back or their lives get worse
is one that i'm i'm very well known for
now the secret
is that you need to focus on yourself
you really shouldn't think about them
and because you never know down the line
they'll come back or
you know they'll start going bald or
something but you just have to focus
on yourself that's the key ben affleck
and jlo right now
think about it he he kind of he's gone a
lot of different ways but he came back
and now they're very happy and
jlo you know she did her she crushed
life in the meantime had amazing
business
lived her best life and and now she's
back with him so she just
focused on herself and there he is we
got to get into some
signature tinx theories let's start with
box theory it's really taken the
internet by storm can you please explain
so box theory is when a guy meets a girl
in a romantic setting so
at a bar sit sits next door to dinner
party gets set up dating app
he puts her into one of three boxes he
wants to date her
he wants to hook up or he wants nothing
to do with her so if if you're in the
third box
move on all very good the other two
boxes
now this theory is supposed to be
freeing because if you're in the date
box
you can do almost anything and it's he's
still going to want to date you you can
get
drunk you can puke on his shoes you can
forget his name and he's still going to
find it totally charming
if you're in the hookup box you can you
know
not sleep with him for weeks on end you
can talk about how much you love
knitting and staying home
and he's still not going to want to date
you the upshot of all this is
don't worry about it do what you want
when you want sleep with a guy
when you want to and you feel ready to
it really
it really doesn't change things and then
comes into play reverse box theory which
i can also talk about
please so reverse box theory is
on the other other side of things a lot
of young women
put guys in the i want to date him box
before he's even worthy of it
but like they'll see him they'll see a
mediocre a dating app profile
they'll ask one of their friends about
him and they're like this is my husband
i must date him
i must date bob from hinge and it's like
you haven't even met bob from hinge this
is not coming from a place of judgment
this is coming from a place of when i
was 22 i would meet a guy once and i'd
be like this
i'm going to marry him i'm completely
obsessed with him and then it screws up
here
you act weird because you're so stressed
can you shift boxes
i would argue very rarely i really would
argue
that you can't because it it's just got
when guys meet you they kind of
categorize you in that way and it's just
it's very rare now is there exceptions
of course there's exceptions to every
rule which is why you should take back
the power
and feel relieved of any stress and just
be
yourself if he's going to love you for
who you are you'll know it and
that's all there is to it so let's talk
about ickless what is an ick list
okay so an ickless is when you start to
see a guy
when you start to date someone um you
keep a list on your phone of a little ix
now for anybody who doesn't know an
ick is like a little thing that they do
or say or something about them that
you're just kind of like
like he doesn't have a headboard is the
classic one that i owe or
he chews with his mouth open myself
included sometimes when you're dating
someone new you can get you can fall
very quickly
and you just have rose-colored glasses
on and everything they do is amazing
even if you're in this mental place
there will be small x
write them in your phone and if you feel
yourself getting all
bajiggity and woowoo read them and bring
yourself back down to earth
and worst case scenario if he goes to
you or he's being rude to you you know
whatever
you can refer to the ick list and think
you know what
he wasn't all that great okay so with
that what is planning a funeral
this is not for if you were in a
relationship this is if you saw someone
casually
and either they soft ghosted you ghosted
you whatever you were seeing them for a
few weeks it didn't work out
we as women spend so much time thinking
what could have been what should have
been should i have worn a different
dress
if only i hadn't put that exclamation
point at the end of that sentence like
enough you need to stop focusing on what
could have been
and start focusing on what you deserve
so in order to do this
you pick pick a day and make a deal with
yourself and say this is the day that i
hold a funeral for him
or yourself a glass of wine go get
yourself a delicious oat milk latte
put on jeff buckley's hallelujah imagine
order some imaginary flowers in your
head
imaginary flowers because your feelings
for him are imaginary you're not
actually in love with him
you're just the idea of him and lay him
to rest
and listen hearing you say all that i i
do want to talk a little bit about you
and your personal life you know you were
so gracious to invite
all of your your friends and your
followers into your journey
as you dated this mystery man that we
simply referred to as
yg yes and then to open our phones and
to see you
you know release a series of videos just
in
tears emotionally telling your followers
that the relationship had ended
today i got a horrible message and
if you have received one of those
messages you know exactly how it feels
you slowly read the words and you start
to feel sick
this was the first guy that i imagined
making a life with
right now i really do feel like my heart
is broken in two
i want to offer you a huge part of my
heart and i just want to ask how are you
doing
i'm good thank you that's so kind you
know what i
as soon as it happened i thought i have
this opportunity to really practice what
i preach right like
i'm i'm in this state of intense pain
and you know something bad happened but
i can practice what i preach and tell
them like i'm not
embarrassed i don't i don't regret
anything i feel
grateful for how happy i was and how how
it reminded me like how much i love and
how deeply i love
and now i have this opportunity to show
followers how you how you show up like
your character is not who you are like
on the best day of your life your
character is
who you are and how you show up when in
the face of adversity
yeah so have you made peace have you
moved on entirely or
are we still working through things i've
made peace and i've moved on and it's
it's time for the next chapter
you have to focus on what you deserve um
and
and i know my worth and and i know how i
deserve to be treated so
100 queen and so i guess is it fair to
ask is tinx back in the dating game
i am back in the dating game yes i am
i'm
slowly slowly submerging it's not a dive
in it's a
it's a it's just a weight in but yes i'm
i'm dipping my toe back and i'm back in
the game
i do want to ask you because i think a
lot of your fans
have really enjoyed watching your
friendship with diplo blossom
and then seeing you with him in vegas
over the weekend
what's the story there he's so sweet you
know diplo and i are friends
um just friends just friends yeah he's a
great guy
i love his music i really am his biggest
fan and i yeah i ran into him in vegas
just by chance
and you know fate brought us together so
um
we had a really fun time running around
uh vegas
for a night but um he's very sweet yeah
okay does he does he have a chance with
tanks
god i don't know i i might i might
friend zone him honestly i i can't tell
but maybe never say never you know
i feel like the next natural step would
be tinx
products you know your own athleisure
line
what are some of the goals that you have
for yourself like specific things that
you want to tackle next
oh my gosh i think um i mean i think
a jump into into audio some some form of
audio would be
incredible just to be able to speak to
my followers directly podcast
radio hosting i want to try it all i
really do
um yeah we'll see i love how you always
joke about how
you're the oldest person you're the
oldest millennial on on tick tock
in 10 years do you still see yourself
making tick tock videos
i honestly do my life began at 30. i
feel younger now than i did when i was
21 and i feel like
i'm just at the beginning of my career
so i absolutely will be
um on tick tock forever it's it's my
home i love it
do you want to get married down the road
would you like to have a family i
definitely want those things i
definitely
want a family and i have to be a rich
mom so
clearly you'll be the freaking leader